is we say good character poor better yet
a good mentor character last week I
spoke at length about beerus and what he
offers the show was he good was he bad
if you haven't seen it check out that
video but it got me thinking about the
other new character that was introduced
does he have the same issues that
plagued beerus or was he a great
inclusion in his own right so like many
of my other videos I took the Twitter
asking if you guys thought he was a good
or a bad inclusion to the series with
almost 4,000 votes cast Wiese was in
high favor among the fanbase with almost
80% claiming to enjoy his inclusion
however in order for me to figure out
how I felt about Wiese and his role as a
mentor character I first needed to
understand what makes a good mentor
character is Dragon Ball there have been
quite a few mentor student relationships
in this series and I want to see how the
angel of the seventh universe measures
up this is my analysis on Dragon Balls
mentor characters and the strongest
being in universe 7 all right what the
hell are you I'm simply the life form
that's known as weas
[Music]
the mentor character was honestly not
one I considered to be of major
importance in the series at least not at
first glance however in writing this
video I've learned more about writing
and specifically dragonball than any
other video I've ever made in the past
and that's because most of the major
plot points throughout Dragon Ball and
Dragonball Z have been developed and
processed through a mentor pupil
relationship characters like Master
Roshi cami and King Kai have played a
major role for long periods of time and
even Goku has assumed the mentor role
when the occasion arose both a Dragon
Ball Z and super but today the question
is does wheeze contribute to the series
in the mentor role as well as those that
came before him well what's interesting
is the mentor character is one of the
most vital roles in most of the
character arcs we've enjoyed within the
series sort of the catalyst for the
character arc if you will I've spoken at
length before about the writing
technique the lie the character believes
as written in Cameron's book creating
character arcs this is when a character
believes something untrue either about
themselves the world or both a mentor
character admonishes the protagonist
with some form of insight that he or she
does not get understand about themselves
or the world they live in
in other words providing the student or
pupil with the teachings or advice they
need to better themselves to find the
truth to correct that lie that they
believe the most important part of a
mentor character is how they relate or
don't relate to the lie the protagonist
beliefs for instance at the very
beginning of Dragon Ball Z go on and
piccolo began one of the more
interesting and complicated mentor
student relationships from the moment we
meet Gohan we learned that he is a timid
fearful child that is capable of much
more than he or anyone else can
comprehend
however the lie that he believes at this
point of the story is that he needs
people to take care of him and he can't
help anyone in a combative effort and
that he is weak both a physical body and
of character however once piccolo gets a
glimpse of this young half Saiyans power
both he and Gohan begin a year-long
stint of training together we're in
piccolo attempts to advise and shoot of
Gohan to trust more in himself during a
mentors teaching a common trope is for
the mentor to reveal information or
replace the pupil into a circumstance
that they are not ready for in the case
of Gohan that was his encounter with the
invading Saiyans
despite having come much farther than he
ever thought he would go one still is
terrified off these alien invaders and
as a result one's the moment he's
depended on furthermore due to his
helplessness due to the
a lie that he believes his mentor
piccolo sacrifices himself to save Gohan
this act inspires the young se to act
more courageously and realized what he
piccolo had been teaching him all arc
long and that's not to say that there
can't be a mentor pupil dynamic that
can't result in a mentor learning
something two instances like this make
for fascinating and believable
characters and once again piccolo and
Gohan demonstrate that perfectly while
piccolo helped Gohan believe in himself
Gohan began to show piccolo that it's
okay to believe in others both of these
characters in this section of the story
undergo a positive change thanks in
large part to the guidance of each other
the result of the mentor-student
relationship and that sort of the idea
behind it at least in one way you see
mentor characters don't always succeed
in helping their pupil in some cases the
mentor fails to understand the student
or puts him or her into a position they
are not yet ready for resulting in them
embracing the light instead of the truth
that was Gauss's mistake when dealing
with soo masu a mistake that he later
admits to in the arc
bouncing off that slightly depressing
note Goku has had more mentors and
Dragon Ball than any of the others so
how does he fit into this whole mentor
student dynamic well as I said before
the mentor is supposed to act as
something of a catalyst for the pupil
characters given archetype and so as I
explained in my very first video of this
series Goku is a terrific example of
what km Wyland calls a flack character
arc in short a flat character arc is
distinctly different from a positive or
negative character arc as seen the likes
of Goines positive arc and Zam a Sue's
negative one wherein the mentor and the
world changes the character for the
better or for the worse however in the
case of the flat character arc the
protagonist or individual isn't burdened
by a lie that they hold to be true and
as a result changes the world around
them for the better instead of the world
changing them transforming a light
burden world is sort of their role
Goku's minor personality changes and
overall maturity in the series don't
detract from his position as a flat
character although I can sort of see the
confusion when I affirm the position
that Goku is an example of a flat
character arc it implies that he doesn't
develop in the narrative as a result of
his archetype but some people have
argued that there are plenty of examples
demonstrating Goku's emotional maturity
and physical maturity in the series and
this is absolutely true however when I
talk about his flat character arc I am
referring to
whose story those accent changes are not
what Goku story is about
unlike piccolo and Vegeta that very
clearly follow a positive change
throughout Goku interacts with the world
and changes it for the better
reaffirming his flat character archetype
a fluff character arc doesn't imply that
he himself doesn't change as a person at
all but that the story that he is on is
it concerned with any changes be they
minor or major that he undergoes whereas
in the case of Vegeta any positive
change was the entire point of his story
and so while keeping in mind that Goku
changed the world around him for the
better presenting a light burden world
with truth and a mentor character is
supposed to act as a catalyst for this
character arc it's only natural that
this happens when he encounters a mentor
character whether it be with Roshi or
King Kai Goku demonstrates time and
again that the expectations of whoever
was around him including his current
mentors would be easily surpassed a
major drawback to these dynamics however
with goku and his mentors is that on
their own
there isn't any conflict like there
would naturally be with dynamics like
Gohan and Zuma soo
for this reason while he was training
with roti Crillon provided that positive
character arc and the conflict for the
story early on but whose training under
comi was largely not shown at all and
with King Kai Gohan's training with
piccolo coupled with the time limit of
the Seine invasion provided it there and
so while it's fun to watch Goku train
under a mentor there has always been
careful planning in place during his
time under tutelage and that's because
under this tutelage Goku doesn't change
from the mentor relationship or at least
not in the way that a character
typically does meaningful change in
these relationships comes from emotional
growth a rejection of their lie and an
adoption of their mentors truth
resulting in a much more satisfying and
happy life for the student character and
so because King Kai didn't offer any
emotional growth for Goku there needed
to be something else to provide that
emotional through-line for the arc which
is why we had Piccolo's death scene at
the hands of nappa and nothing nearly as
emotional for Goku and the reason I'm
going through all of this is because
it's sort of important to understand
because it will inform our understanding
of Goku and Vegeta's time spent under
Wiese as well as his involvement in this
series of Dragon Ball
super I love spring now before I say
anything I want to make clear that by
much like the other 80 some percent of
you really genuinely like we say a
personality but oftentimes it's easy to
forget that these characters are just
that individuals created to serve a
purpose within a fictional story making
arguments for them based off of
character and who they might be or what
they might do instead of utility and
story leads us down a very strange path
of hypotheticals and hyperbole so yes I
do like weeks as a personality I think
both voice actors from Japan in the u.s.
offer a wonderful humanity and sass to
him that elevates his likability
exponentially across the board which is
great
he adds an interesting dynamic to beerus
that elevates his character too and he
adds a massive sense of scale when it
comes to the ability for the main cast
and what's to come for them but given
what we now understand is the desired
utility and optimal effect a mentor
character should have within a series
for a positive negative and flat arc
character let's take a look at how
rhesus inclusion contributes to those
the beginning of Lisa's training sees
two different beginnings during
resurrection F and within Dragon Ball
super TV series and while there are
differences between both most notably in
Dragon Ball super where Vegeta seeks out
training first as he is still obsessed
with catching up to Goku both result in
the same advice being lobbed towards the
respective students
recent forms Goku that his
overconfidence is his shortcoming and
Vegeta's is his tense unrelaxed
composure this is presented such that if
they can overcome this mental block they
will attain what later becomes known as
ultra instant while both of these pieces
of advice are interesting and worth
delving into more once the resurrection
F portion of the story completes Goku's
problem isn't touched on ever again and
Vegeta's is only briefly alluded to via
body language in less than a few scenes
throughout and at the very end where he
decides to stop chasing Goku suddenly
neither Goku nor Vegeta had any
emotional growth in these lessons from
wastes in the case of Vegeta suddenly
shifting from obsessing over his
position compared with Goku to not
caring at all blazing his own Trail is
not development when something happens
without prior reasoning or emotional
growth that's called character
convenience not character growth without
lines two distinct and easily understood
shortcomings within
both of these fighters and the closest
thing we get to development shockingly
is through Goku who gets taken out due
to this very shortcoming but afterwards
this lesson isn't necessarily learned it
just happens and everyone sort of moves
on Goku's overconfidence is then on
display throughout the rest of super
thereafter
despite being shown to train alongside
Vegeta and we store the remainder of the
series realistically this advice should
conflict with Goku's emotional state and
ultimately culminate in him accepting
this shortcoming and adopting a better
way of life but then that would be
contradicting Goku's character type Goku
if you remember already has the truth
he's a flat character AK and therefore
gory emotionally doesn't come easily to
him so nothing happens Dragon Ball Z his
workaround for this was to have Goku
impress his mentors or simply not show
his training at all and during these
times others would either be by his side
in these efforts to provide the
necessary struggle or occupying an
adjacent part of the story like piccolo
and Gohan did with in this instance in
Dragon Ball super they tried to give
Goku an emotional fault alongside Vegeta
in Goku's case it's flat out forgotten
about and in the case of Aegina it just
suddenly happens without any gradual
introspection or struggle on bejeezus
behalf specifically concerning this
inability to relax now it could be
argued that we suppose in a no-win
scenario with this particular plotline
it sort of existed to create the twist
ending for the resurrection F arc and
nothing more and I think that's a fair
way to look at it but that still doesn't
mean that least did a good job
the Warriors didn't struggle emotionally
to learn anything and as a result we
never got any cathodic moments due to
these lessons we Swiss espousing which
brings me to my final critique of his
character the exposition in John
troubies book the anatomy of story he
writes you never want to create
characters that sound like a mouthpiece
for your ideas good writers express
their moral vision slow and subtly
primarily through story structure and
the way the hero deals with a particular
situation and the Falla character is
there for is to monologue exposition in
obvious ways or to facilitate magical
deus ex machina type plot device endings
at least in my opinion it leaves a lot
to be desired which is a crying shame of
the highest order because as I said
before I adore Wiese and the style of
personality that he's portrayed as
having he's charming interesting and
boasts a wonderful
design but much like many of the other
changes in storylines Dragon Ball super
has delivered it's being far from super
and closer to mediocre and short-sighted
and that's what I learned in this video
somewhat fittingly this video about
mentor characters has taught me more
about story dynamics and Dragon Ball
than perhaps any of the others I've made
and I've made quite a few I loved Wiese
as much as the next guy and Anson Claire
is my spirit animal in reality I think
the issues I have with wheeze can be
boiled down to a side effect of a much
more broader issue that lies within
Dragon Ball super itself and perhaps
it's high time I began to dig deeper and
talk more about that but until then
thank you so much for watching
you